welcome to a new week of news and
politics in the united states i want to
start today by
trying at least to run some interference
and introduce some facts into the wild
disinformation really is what it is
disinformation and ignorance and talking
points that are spreading
about crime in the united states because
there there are actually some i believe
well-intentioned people including people
on the left
who are are falling for some of these
talking points and are
ending up in places where they certainly
shouldn't be and one of the things that
can become difficult particularly right
now is that one of the techniques that
the right uses
is to continually you could say move the
goal posts you can say to gish gallup
which is just to throw a whole bunch of
stuff out making it hard to refute
each piece but if you did refute each
piece you would realize
there's really nothing there and the
area where i'm going to focus on today
is crime
because in the wake of the george floyd
protests in the context of
calls from some on the left to either
defund or abolish the police in a
broader context where
most of the left wants to reform you're
starting to hear
all of these subsequent steps being
taken to get to
joe biden will cancel all police and
your kids will be killed as a result of
it right like that's where they want to
end up
there's all these intermediate steps and
one of those steps is
crime is going up there's more crime
right now and
they talk about this in the context of
portland and chicago often by playing
you know 30 second clips of this or that
thing happening so we
we absolutely have to go step by step
so first and foremost if we're going to
talk about
whether defunding police once joe biden
does it
we'll do x or y to rising crime rates
we've got to figure out is that actually
joe biden's plan would
such plans if they existed actually be
successful but most importantly is crime
going up right now and crime rates in
the united states on a year-to-year
basis have been declining that is
the first fact we have to introduce here
because the entire conversation stems
from that
despite the fact that we have more and
more people living in the united states
over time
actual crime rates for things like
violent crime robbery property crimes
it has all been declining on a per
household basis
when you survey people and you ask them
do you
think crime has increased in the united
states from last year
almost every year more than 50 percent
of the people in the united states
believe that yes
crime has actually gone up so crime has
been going down
since the early 90s people mostly
believe
crime has been going up okay that's step
one
now there are a whole bunch of other
details and
complications that warrant some more
exploration so let's do a couple of them
before we move on
for example some types of crime might be
up one year
even in the midst of a downward trend or
some types of crime might be up one year
even when other types of crime are down
so as an example
in 2020 murder is up slightly but a
whole bunch of other crimes
are down and over time all of these
types of violent crime
are down so you would have to decide can
i really make any relevant observation
in one year about well murder's up
but rape and robbery are down and arson
is up but
burglary and sexual assault or whatever
right so
overall crime rates have been declining
for a long time and they continue to
decline
it's also important to remember that not
all crimes are reported to police so
anytime we're looking at something that
depends on reporting to
an authority you have to consider that
the records
may not reflect reality at equal rates
so as an example which many on the right
don't like
sexual assault is notoriously
under-reported
however that doesn't really fit into
their narrative if they want to make it
seem as though crime in general is
under-reported you really have to start
with sexual assault which they don't
seem particularly willing to do
then you have other crimes crimes like
vandalism and public intoxication
which arguably should not even really be
a crime which
certainly are visible in that you see
graffiti or a broken window
or with whatever the case may be but
those are not the serious violent crimes
that we're really mostly talking about
when we talk about how police should be
reformed
so that gets us to what's going on today
since the george floyd protests have
started
we've been hearing uh defund the police
we've been hearing abolish the police
we've been hearing reform
we've been hearing just fund the police
blindly give them as much money as they
want we've heard every combination of
things
the majority of the left including joe
biden
is talking about reform uh it could
include reallocation of funds taking
funds away maybe from militarization
while
increasing funds for training as one
example but
it doesn't really matter in terms of the
crime we're seeing now because remember
all of the discussions about defunding
abolishing restructuring
all that stuff it's in the future it
hasn't happened yet and yet still you
have people like donald trump himself
and his acolytes tweeting videos of
things going on now
in uh you know portland or chicago
saying
this is the future of the country if joe
biden is elected president
hold on a second first of all that's
trump's america right now
so to say this is what's going on now
and this is
what would be happening even more under
joe biden you then have to see
does what is it that joe biden would do
that would exacerbate this and there
actually isn't anything
but it also ignores that none of these
abolish or defund things have become a
reality so
they are arguing we are seeing more
crime in cities
because police have been defunded by
democrats the reality is crime continues
to go down
and nothing's been defunded yet there
have been some conversations in certain
places about
how might we reduce funding to police in
some places
you know northampton massachusetts is a
place where the show started where
there's been this discussion
there's been a decrease to the rate at
which police funding will
increase if that makes sense um but
all of this stuff is in the future so
you certainly
can't blame a future
possible changes to police funding for
current increases in crime particularly
when there have been no such increases
today
there have been discussions about do we
change who responds to certain types of
911
when they relate to homelessness or
mental illness as an example okay
those discussions have been had there
are some places that have started to
look at making some of those changes but
these policies haven't yet been put in
place when it comes to defund or abolish
i don't think that they are going to and
joe biden certainly doesn't
uh support them so when you look at this
broader context
you do have to ask why are people
falling for the idea that crime is up
and this actually takes me back to my
days as an undergrad at the university
of massachusetts amherst
where uh michael morgan who's been a
guest on this program
studied this extensively eric ashar
also studied this and both of those
interviews are on the youtube channel
there's often this assumption and we see
it after mass shootings we see it after
a lot of things
that violence in the media and in
popular culture in movies and video
games
makes people act violently in the real
world
now by and large that doesn't seem to be
true
it if you look at the scholarship on
this it's certainly possible that people
already predisposed to be violent in the
real world
might be triggered to act um in a
particular way
based on things they consume in violent
video games or movies but that's a small
small portion of the population by and
large we have not
found that violent video games or
watching violent news or
or whatever makes people violent in the
new in the real world
however what does seem to be the case is
that seeing
violence on the news and in media may
make
people more afraid and it makes people
believe
that the world is more dangerous than it
is and in fact
when you look at local news and you
realize wow murder is down over the last
30 years all of these violent crimes are
down over the last 30 years
but the representation in media is
identical or has even grown because of
this if it bleeds
it leads ideology it makes sense that
based on watching news people would
believe the world is more dangerous than
it is people would believe there is more
crime
than there actually is so what you have
right now
in part thanks to the trump
administration uh
is this use it's all based on getting
trump reelected and we're going to deal
with that a little bit more later in the
show
you have a lot of discussion of very
rare
individual incidents that are happening
in the shadows of mostly peaceful
protests but the takeaway we have to
remember
is that crime rates have been on the
decline since the 90s and there
certainly has been no defunding of the
police yet
which you could blame for non-existent
crime increases that they claim exist
now one other thing that i think is
important to think about
and that's the war on drugs and prison
populations
some will say clearly there is more
crime
because people are in prison for
committing crimes more than ever before
there are more people in prison right
now so clearly there's more crime going
on
just because there are more people in
prison doesn't mean that the streets of
the united states are more dangerous
from a violent crime
standpoint if you add things to the list
of stuff that will get you put in prison
you would expect that more people are
going to end up in prison
if you put in place mandatory minimums
or if judicial discretion is used
to sentence people to longer prison
sentences
you can see prisons more full even
if violent crime is on the decline in
general society
which it is so it's really important not
to fall for that propaganda
because at every level there there is to
go back to the beginning there is a gish
gallop going on
where a whole bunch of stuff is thrown
out crime is up
and it's crime because it's up because
police have been defunded and joe biden
would do more of that
you've got to break it down is crime up
no uh
have police been defunded already in a
way that would even relate to what we're
seeing right now
no does joe biden want to defund the
police if
if he becomes president no every single
one
of the premises is wrong and they count
on
because they don't have the facts on
their side side they count on you not
knowing the facts
or you not checking the facts and ending
up having to argue on the merits and
when we accept the facts
and debate what should be done we're
missing the fact that the premises are
all wrong hopefully this is useful when
we see
everything from don jr's tweets to
discussions in right-wing media
and on the internet about these issues
go and look at whether the premises make
sense and check out in this case
they don't starting with crime has been
on a downward trend
for decades in the united states let me
know what you think i'm on twitter at
deepakman
we have a lot happening this week this
is the month
of the 15-year anniversary of the david
pakman show can you imagine that and
i'll talk to you later on in the month
about
what we're going to do the exact date is
in the second half of the month
uh but a very very exciting month we'll
take a quick break and be back right
after this
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video